hello everyone how are you guys doing
hope you guys are having a wonderful day
and today we are here with episode 10 of
my money-making series basically in the
series I go and I show I showcase a ton
of different money-making methods in the
game this one that I'll be doing today
is around 1.2 to 1.3 mil per hour I
believe um it isn't the best I've
uploaded but it has pretty low
requirements and it is very RNG heavy so
you can get really lucky or really
unlucky with this so if you're feeling
like you want to test out your luck a
little bit you can go ahead try out this
method and see if it works for you
basically the requirements for this
method are very minuscule I personally
have 58 thieving 51 I would believe
would be around the lowest that I would
go but you could do it with 41 however
51 is the lowest I would do it with
anything higher than that is definitely
helpful and will increase your GP per
hour by a little bit nothing too
significant but it'll definitely help
you out so from there we are doing the
feros spor method as I have mentioned
previously basically you're going to be
going through pyramid plunder and trying
to find Ferro scepter so the gear that
you're going to want personally I have a
hit points cape and a regen bracelet
you're going to want things that boost
back your HP the regen bracelet and hit
points Cape if I wear them both means
that I heal once every 15 seconds I heal
one HP so there's no point of me using
rapid heal as I will not be stacking
rapid heal along with those as you
cannot it just won't let you do that it
won't let you stack three of those
things so you can do any combination of
you could do rapid heal in a hit point
Escape you could do rapid heal in a
regen bracelet I believe would be the
most viable option and the most
accessible but that's up to you if you
end up going about the rapid heal method
basically what you're going to want to
do is pretty much bring prayer boosting
equipment like an ancient rope top and
legs you're going to want to sto some
sort of book and that's about it
personally I end up using one prayer
every 30 seconds so I mean with full
prayer points I could last on a trip for
45 minutes and that's without even using
my food so I'd be pretty well off also
on top of that you're going to want to
go ahead and have a DDS or some sort of
weapon because there are scarabs in here
which will prevent you from searching
the other things in the room which is
going to be detrimental to your GP per
hour so personally I always keep the
spec on and auto retaliate off you could
also have Piet up here or some sort of
prayer that increases melee as a quick
prayer and go ahead and use that
whenever you go to speca
Scarab so from there what are you going
to need in your inventory just a feros
scepter and I usually or I would
recommend keeping 12 spaces open so that
you are able to recharge your feros
scepter and I'll go more into to that as
we move on all right so from there I'm
going to go ahead and show you basically
what you're going to want to do and then
I'll get into a little more of the
calculation side and how I came about
finding the GP per hour for this method
so once you have all the gear and
everything that you're going to need
you're going to want to use your feros
sceptor just left click it and just
click whatever the first option is I'm
not going to try to pronounce that then
from there you'll be at the mummy so
once at the mummy you'll either want to
talk to him if you've never done pent
plunder before or if you have go ahead
and do start mini game and get right
into it so from there you'll be entered
in the first room pass the spear traps
go ahead and just try to navigate those
yourself you may fail sometimes however
right here I got lucky enough to pass
through so here this is the grand gold
chest you're going to want to go ahead
and search that but first search the
sarcophagus basically because the
scarabs are a lot harder to deal with in
every room so ideally you'd want to
search this first cuz you can you can
search this while a mummy is attacking
you like that one is there if the
scarabs get on you though you have no
chance this is the examp example of the
first room you're then going to want to
go on and look through all of these
Corner doors and try to find the room
that leads into the next room so once
you have found that you'll be entered
into the next room and repeat the
process until you get to the room that
you have the level required by a factor
of 10 so if one room requires 61 and
you're at 65 thev you won't be able to
go into the next room so once you
realize that and once you search both of
them go ahead and just exit through the
leaf tomb door like I will do here in a
second so from here go ahead and press
quick leave personally I'm just doing
this early just to demonstrate once out
of the pyramid you're going to want to
go ahead and click on the Ferro scepter
again this will be the most useful way
of constantly making money and making
this faster so from there go ahead and
start up your mini game again one more
thing I should mention is this Ferro
scepter will run out of charges after
three uses so what you're going to want
to do and why I have all these inventory
spaces open is because you're going to
want to fill them with stone items once
you get 12 stone items you can recharge
this scepter by talking to him before
you go into the mini game you can also
do this with six gold or 24 Pottery or I
think it's yeah 24 Pottery ones um the
gold are obviously the easiest to do it
with but you don't get them as often so
that's why I do it with stone all right
so that is it for the guide part of this
video so if that was helpful feel free
to leave a like if you guys want to
stick around and know actually how I
figured out how much money per hour this
was go ahead and stick around with me
for a second while I explain that so
basically if Once Upon looking this up
you'll find that the gold chest and the
sarcophagus both have a one in onek
chance of being able to drop you a Ferro
scepter now it comes with the added
information that that is as long as a
mummy or a swarm does not appear out of
the sarcophagus or chest so it isn't
necessarily too easy to figure out so I
had to do about 100 not 100 runs but I
opened up about 100 chests in total
basically what I found is there is a 16
out of 52 chance of there actually being
something that hops out at you which is
about a 30% chance so from there I ended
up finding that you would actually have
to find in total or at least search 1.4
28 so 1428 chests in total to actually
be on average of finding a feros scepter
so with that I kind of calculated with
91 thieving how much you'd be able to
find and by 58 how much you'd be able to
find this is purely based on the fact
that you don't have to restart your run
every four doors instead or every four
rooms in instead it's every eight rooms
so that's how that changes also on top
of that from what I read the higher
level you go in the rooms the less
likely you are to have a swarm or mummy
pop out personally I couldn't test that
cuz I don't have 91 thieving and I
wasn't going to get 91 thieving purely
to have the exact right amount of GP per
hour that you can make so with 58
thieving you can end up making about 1.1
mil per hour as you'll have to be here
for about 7 hours on average to find a
feros scepter now with 91 thieving you
should be making about 1.2 mil per hour
as you will be here for 6.6 hours on
average to find a Ferro scepter so hope
that was helpful for you guys hope that
kind of explains how I came about
finding that GP per hour if this video
was helpful in any way shape or forward
feel free to hit that like button if you
guys want to see more of my content in
the future hit the sub button it would
be much appreciated definitely helps out
the channel if you guys want to know
more about me hit up the Twitter and uh
yeah other than that I mean you guys got
anything to tell me leave it down below
but other than that hope you guys have a
wonderful day and peace had a lot of fun
making this video definitely
and
[Music]